Tổng mật cả sĩ sẽ hữu cành YouTube hình hai trong nghìn người đang ký với nhiều video chụp view.
Phương giữuền vừa bị công an thành phố Hồ Chí Minh khởi tổ về tội sâm phạm quyền tác giả quyền liên quan.
Vậy, phương giữuền là ai.
Phương giữuền tên thật quyến thị hình bà mi tữ tội là cả sĩ tự gió theo đổi giống nhật mô lề rô và trước tình.
Cô bắt đầu các hát từ năm 2018 và được viên đến sau khi dành giải nhất của thị sản chính giận hát năm 2020.
Trong một cuộc phòng bánh trước đây, mữ ká sĩ chia sẻ dời công việc kinh doanh để tàn tâm theo đổi còn đường ká hát.
Cá khúc lấy người khu yếu được cô xem là giống mốt trong sự nghiệp khi đặt cình bà trở là xem sau bốn tháng phát hành trên YouTube.
Thấy vì đầu quên cho công ty, phương giữuền trọn hoạt động lập từ sản xuất khách sản phẩm âm nhạc và nhiều lần bây tỏ mong muốn được khán giả tiếp tục cuộc khu cành YouTube của mình.
Theo con quan thành phố Hồ Chí Minh, Wynh Thị Hền là chủ sử khu cành YouTube phương giữ nhìn hình hợp tác với bây hát mệt đi à, quản lý cân có hơn 200 gỷ và khoảng 1 gỷn sấu trăm video.
Cơ quan điều tra sắc định trong thời gian dài, hình đã đăng tải nhiều tác phẩm âm nhạc lên YouTube, mà không sinh phép không trả tiện bản quyền.
Hình vì này bị cho là người thị thải hàng trong trộ động cho các tác dạ, lồng thời giúp bị càng thù lợi bất chính hàng trong trộ động từ nền tạc YouTube.
Hồi nguyện thị hình, cơ quan điều tra cũng khơi tổ nguyện thịnh hợp giám đốc công việc hỗ hạt chuyển thân bà dại chỉ yêu đi con Việt Nam về cùng hành vi.